there's this idea of the semantic web
that when i first heard about
i just fell in love with the idea it was
the obvious next step for the internet
sure
and uh maybe you can speak about what is
the semantic web what are your thoughts
about it
how your vision and mission and goals
with psych are connected integrated
like are they dance partners are they
aligned what are your thoughts there so
think of the semantic web as a kind of
knowledge graph and google already has
something they call knowledge graph for
example
which is sort of like a node and link
diagram so you have these
nodes that represent concepts or words
or terms
and then there are some arcs
that connect them that might be labeled
um and so you might have a node
with like one person that represents one
person and um uh
let's say a um a husband link
that then points to that person's
husband and so there'd be then another
link that went from that person labeled
wife that went back to the first node
and so on so
having having this kind of
representation is really good if you
want to represent
binary relations
um
essentially relations between two things
and if you so if you have um
um equivalent of like three word
sentences
um you know like uh
fred's wife is wilma or something like
that you can represent that very nicely
using uh these kinds of
graph structures or using something like
the semantic web and
and so on but the the problem is that
very often what you want to be able to
express
takes a lot more than three words and a
lot more than simple
graph structures like that to represent
so for instance um
if you've
read or seen romeo and juliet you know i
could say to you something like
remember when juliet drank the potion
that put her into a kind of suspended
anime animation when juliet drank that
potion
what did she think that romeo would
think
when he heard from someone that she was
dead
and you could basically understand what
i'm saying you can understand the
question you could probably remember the
answer was well she thought that um this
friar would have gotten a message to
romeo saying that she was going to do
this but the friar didn't and so so um
you're able to represent and reason with
these much much much more complicated
expressions
um that go way way beyond what simple um
three as it were three word or forward
english sentences are which is really
what the semantic web can represent and
really what knowledge graphs can
represent if you could step back for a
second because it's funny you went into
specifics and maybe you can elaborate
but i was also referring to semantic web
as the vision
of converting
data on the internet into something
that's interpretable
understandable by machines oh of course
at that at that level so so i would say
like what is the semantic web
i mean you could say a lot of things but
it might not be obvious to a lot of
people when they do a google search
that just like you said while there
might be something that's called a
knowledge graph
it's really boils down to
keyword search
ranked by the quality estimate of the
website
integrating previous human
based google searches and what they
thought was useful it's like some weird
combination of um
like surface
level hacks that work exceptionally well
but they don't understand the content
the full contents of the websites that
they're searching so google does not
understand
to the degree we've been talking about
the word understand
the contents of the wikipedia pages as
part of the search process and the
semantic web says
let's try to get
come up with a way for the computer to
be able to truly understand the contents
of those pages that's the dream yes so
let me let me first give you a an
attitude
and then i'll answer your question
so there's a search engine you've
probably never heard of called northern
light
and um
it went out of business but the way it
worked it was a kind of vampiric
search engine and what it did was it
didn't index
the internet at all
all it did was it
negotiated and got access to
data
from the big search engine companies
about what query was typed in
and
where the user ended up
being happy and actually um then you
know they type in a completely different
query unrelated query and so on so it
just went from query to
the web page that seemed to satisfy them
eventually
and that's all so it had actual no
understanding of what was being typed in
it had no statistical data other than
what i just mentioned and it did a
fantastic job it did such a good job
that the big search engine company said
oh we're not going to sell you this data
anymore so then it went out of business
because it had no other way of
taking users to where they would want to
go and so on and of course the search
engines
are now using that kind of idea yes
so um let's go back to what you said
about the semantic web so the dream tim
berners-lee and others
dream about the semantic web at a
general level
is of course
exciting and powerful and in a sense the
right
dream to have which is to
replace the the kind of
statistically
statistically mapped
linkages on the internet
into something that's more meaningful
and semantic and actually gets at the
understanding of the content and so on
um and
um
eventually if you say well how can we do
that um there's um
sort of a low road which is what the
knowledge graphs are doing and
and so on which is to say well if we
just use these simple binary relations
we can actually get some fraction of the
way toward understanding
and do something where you know in the
in the land of the the blind the
one-eyed man is king
kind of thing and so being able to even
just have a toe in the water in the
right direction is fantastically
powerful
and so that's where a lot of people stop
but then you could say well what if we
really wanted to represent
and reason with
the full meaning of what's there for
instance
about
romeo and juliet um with the reasoning
about what juliet believes that romeo
will believe that juliet believed you
know and so on or if you look at on the
news what um you know president biden
believed that
the leaders of the taliban would believe
about the leaders of afghanistan if they
you know blah blah so
in order to represent
complicated
sentences like that
let alone reason with them you need
something which is logically
much more expressive than these simple
triples than these simple
knowledge graph type structures and so
on and that's why kicking and screaming
we were led from something like
the semantic web representation which is
where we started in
1984
with frames and slots with those kinds
of triples triple store representation
we were led kicking and screaming to
this more and more general logical
language this higher order logic so
first we were led to first order logic
and then second order and then
eventually higher order so you can
represent things like
modals like beliefs desires intents
expects and so nested ones you can
represent
complicated kinds of negation
you can represent
the process you're going through in
trying to answer the question so you can
say things like um oh yeah if you're
trying to do this problem by integration
by parts
um and
you recursively get a problem that's
solved by integration by parts that's
actually okay but if that happens a
third time you're probably off on a wild
goose chase or something like that so
being able to talk about the
problem-solving process as you're going
through the problem-solving process um
it's called reflection and so um that's
another so it's important to be able to
represent that exactly you need to be
able to represent all of these things um
because in fact people do represent them
they do talk about them they do try and
teach them to other people you do have
rules of thumb that key off of them and
so on if you can't represent it um then
it's sort of like someone with a limited
vocabulary who can't understand as
easily
what you're trying to to tell them and
so that's that's really why i think that
the the general dream the original dream
of semantic web is exactly right on um
but the implementations that we've seen
um are sort of these toe in a walk in
the water
little tiny baby steps in the right
direction you should just dive in
and
and you know if if no one else is diving
in then yes taking a baby step in the
right direction is better than nothing
but it's not going to be sufficient to
actually get you the um the realization
of the semantic web dream which is what
we all want from a flip side of that i
always wondered you know i built a bunch
of websites just for fun whatever
or say i'm a wikipedia contributor
do you think there's a set of tools
that i can help
psych
uh
interpret the website i create you know
like this again
pushing on to the semantic web dream is
there something from the creator
perspective that um
could be done and one of the things you
said uh with scicorp and psych that
you're doing is the tooling side making
humans more powerful but is there any
the other humans in the other side that
create the knowledge like for example
you and i are having a two three
whatever hour conversation now is there
a way that i could
convert this more make it more
accessible to psych to machines do you
think about that side of it
i
i'd love to see
exactly that kind of
semi-automated
understanding of what people write and
what people say
i think of it as a kind of
footnoting almost
almost like the way that when you run
something in say microsoft word or some
other document preparation system google
docs or something you'll get
underlining of questionable things that
you might want to rethink either you
spelled this wrong or there's a strange
grammatical error you might be making
here or something so i'd like to think
in terms of
psych powered tools
that
read through what it is you said or
have typed in
and
and try to
partially understand
what you've said and then you help them
out exactly and then they put in little
footnotes that will help other readers
and they put in certain footnotes of the
form
i'm not sure what you meant here you
either meant this or this or this i bet
if you take a few seconds to
disambiguate this for me
then i'll know and i'll have it correct
for the next
100 people or the next hundred thousand
people who come here
and
if
it doesn't take too much effort
and you want people to understand your
web
your website content
not just be able to read it but actually
be able to have systems that reason with
it then yes it will be worth your small
amount of time
to go back and make sure
that the ai trying to understand it
really did correctly understand it
and you know let's say you run a
a travel
website or something like that and
people are going to be coming to it
because of searches they did
looking for
looking for vacations that or trips that
had certain properties and
might have been interesting to them for
various reasons
things like that and if you've
explained
what's going to happen on your trip
then a system will be able to
mechanically reason
and connect
what this person is looking for with
what it is you're actually
offering and so if it understands that
there's a free day in geneva
switzerland
then
if the person coming in
happens to let's say
be a nurse or something like that
then even though you didn't mention it
if it can look up the fact that that's
where the international red cross museum
is and so on what that means and so on
then it can basically say hey you might
be interested in this trip because while
you have a free day in geneva you might
want to visit that red cross museum
and now
even though it's not very deep reasoning
little tiny factors like that might very
well cause you to sign up for that trip
rather than some competitor trip yeah
and so there's a lot of benefit with seo
and i actually kind of think
i think this about a lot of things which
is
the actual
interface the design of the interface
makes a huge difference
how
efficient it is to
be productive and also how
full of joy the experiences yeah like i
i mean i would love to help a machine
and not from an ai perspective just as a
human one of the reasons i really
enjoy how tesla uh have implemented
their autopilot system
is there's a sense that you're helping
this machine learn
now i think humans i mean having
children
pets people love doing that we
there's joy to teaching
for some people but i think for a lot of
people and
that if you create the interface where
it feels like you're teaching as opposed
to like
uh like annoying
like correcting an annoying system
more like teaching a child like innocent
curious system i think i think you can
literally just like several orders of
magnitude scale the amount of good
quality data being added to something
like psych what what you're suggesting
is much better even
than
you thought it was
one of the
one of the experiences that we've all
had
in our lives
is that we thought we understood
something but then we found we really
only understood it when we had to teach
it or explain it to someone or help our
child do homework based on it or
something like that
despite the universality of that kind of
experience if you look at educational
software today
almost all of it has the computer
playing the role of the teacher
and the student plays the role of the
student
but as i just mentioned you can get a
lot of
learning to happen better and as you
said more enjoyably
if you are the mentor or the teacher and
so on so we developed a program called
math craft to help sixth graders better
understand math
and
it doesn't actually try to teach you the
player
anything what it does is it casts you in
the role of
a student essentially who has
classmates who are having trouble and
your job is to watch them as they
struggle with some math problem watch
what they're doing and try to give them
good advice to get them to understand
what they're doing wrong and so on
and
the trick from the point of view of
psych is it has to make mistakes it has
to play the role of the student who
makes mistakes but it has to pick
mistakes which are just at the fringe
of what you actually understand and
don't understand and so on so it pulls
you
into a deeper and deeper level of
understanding of the subject and so if
you give it good advice about what it
should have done instead of what it did
and so on
then
psych knows that you now understand that
mistake you won't make that kind of
mistake yourself as much anymore so
psych stops making that mistake because
there's no pedagogical usefulness to it
so from your point of view as the player
you feel like you've taught it something
because it used to make this mistake and
now it doesn't and so on so this
tremendous
reinforcement and engagement
because of that and so on so having a
system that plays the role of
a student and having the player play the
role of the mentor is enormously
powerful
type of
metaphor just important uh way of having
this sort of interface designed in a way
which will facilitate exactly the kind
of learning by teaching
um that
that goes on all the time
in our lives and yet which is not
reflected anywhere almost in a modern
education system it was reflected in the
education system
that existed in europe in the 17 and
1800s monitorial and lancastrian
education systems it occurred in the
one-room schoolhouse in the american
west
in the 1800s and so on where you had one
school room with one teacher and it was
basically you know five-year-olds to 18
year olds
who were students and so while the
teacher was doing something
half the half of the students would have
to be mentoring the younger kids
and so on and that turned out to of
course
with scaling up of education
that all went away
and that incredibly powerful experience
just went away from the whole education
institution as we know it today
you